when did you fall in love
With Rockets So yeah so the the story
kind of keeps going for me so I was
doing Sergeant
can't talk photography man we'll get
we'll go on a deep Rabbit Hole there so
um so it ended uh you know I'm through
all this doing a lot of weddings I was
already getting saturated and feeling
like I'm not being as creative you know
you can only shoot him so many weddings
before you're like well now we do this
pose this pose this pose you know even
if like they're amazing places like you
know in front of a castle in Germany or
something I'm still like well at the end
of the day I'm
I'm not being very creative you know so
I remember craving like some some
projects and so I was sitting at my
friend's coffee shop
in my hometown in Cedar Falls sidecar
coffee and I'm sitting on this red couch
and I see this article from I think
Gizmodo and I said you could own
the flight stick of an Apollo Command
Module
and I knew enough to know what that
meant but that's really about the end of
my space knowledge and so I clicked on
it the click bait got me like I'm like
oh yeah I'm gonna see if you know and I
see that the minimum bid is like 250 000
I'm like okay no I can't own the Apollo
joystick you know but I got me on this
website called RR auction and so I
started scrolling through that looking
for things that hadn't been bid on and
they had that you know at the time
they're doing a huge space auction and
so I'm looking for things just out of
curiosity fun these are cool like
they're starting to really you know like
I said I liked space but I wasn't like
in love with it or anything but I'm very
just seeing all the stuff like this is
so cool look at all this old history
stuff
ended up seeing a um there's an article
for a VM SDK 44 flight suit high
altitude flight suit that came from the
Soviet Union
and looks you know it's like a MIG
fighter jet fighter pilot suit very
similar to like the SR-71 like kind of
pumpkin suit
um semi-pressure suit with a you know
full helmet I mean it full it looks like
a spacesuit you know for all intents and
purposes it's kind of like a spacesuit
and I just bid on it you know I've been
like I think 325 dollars and next thing
you know like it arrives at my door
yeah and from that point on like
literally I got it out I immediately try
to put it on and the first thing that I
do is almost die in it because I closed
the helmet down on myself and locked it
and didn't know how to unlock it so I'm
literally and so as soon as I seal it up
I'm realizing I can't breathe I'm going
to run out of air so luckily like
there's a hose you know that kind of
that long hose thing that would normally
plug into an Air Supply had a little
plug on the end of it so I just
unplugged it and was able to temporarily
breathe through the hose until I figured
out the locking mechanism
so there was my almost that was my
mortality rate thing right there so that
was probably above a 98 or below
panicking inside yeah for a few seconds
already reading like my premature
obituary like idiot dies alone in space
suit in his living room you know like
just imagine yeah that would be like
Darwin Award for sure for sure oh so um
so I get the spacesuit and it kind of
literally take my breath away
um
you should feel bad for that one you you
introduced Creed to me so you should
feel bad about that one star's wide open
yeah
okay so
um so I ended up like the space do kind
of like more or less haunted me because
it kind of just it sat in like my living
room for a long time and I didn't know
what to do with it and I actually had a
friend who is also a photographer wanted
to do like a photo he was just kind of
taking pictures randomly he's like hey
bring your spacesuit over we'll do a
picture it's like all right you know I
walk across the street literally lived
across the street Taylor and I and I put
the spacesuit on I took this funny
picture of me like this is awesome and I
got a lot of like fun out of like
creating a character you know of
everyday astronaut or at the time I
guess I didn't know an astronaut and
then that kind of just continued I was
like thinking of more and more funny
situations where I could have this
astronaut on earth doing mundane
everyday things and came up with the
name everyday astronaut and originally
it was just literally a photo project
like this whole art series of an
astronaut doing these things these funny
Whimsical you know Silly mundane things
but I was researching a lot about like
you know I was trying to hide Easter
eggs like I was gonna hide in like the
you know the echocardiogram of of Alan
Shepard you know like his first flight
into space and photoshopping that into
pictures and like you know doing all
these little like facts about space
fight but they're just hidden little
elements in these photos and man doing
that I just fell in love with it I just
was going over every little detail that
I could learn I just couldn't stop
learning and I was I was getting excited
because I was like I could be teaching
people about all this exciting stuff and
all the cool things people figured out
you know 40 years ago 50 years ago and
was trying to portray that through
images on Instagram and you know it it
took me a little while but eventually I
realized you know on Instagram your
retention rate you're lucky if you get
like two seconds of someone looking at
an image you know or maybe nowadays 60
seconds of a quick little Instagram
short or something
but um
yeah it doesn't give you a chance to
really teach to explore a little topic
that you felt like you felt the
Curiosity about the thing there's so
much to learn here this is so beautiful
there's so many opportunities to have a
light bulb go off for someone to be like
this is awesome